antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et bienvenue sur
le plateau du journal à la une ce soir
le parler vrai de michel rocard en
nouvelle calédonie s'adressant aux
caldoches le premier ministre a
notamment déclaré je cite ces propos il
ya eu le temps du pardon il faut que
viennent maintenant le temps du partage
un langage direct que nous analyserons
dans quelques instants avec nos envoyés
spéciaux
avant cela voici les autres temps forts
de l'actualité
nette aggravation du chômage en juillet
+1 24% la france compte 35 mille 200
chômeurs supplémentaires soit 10 4% de
la population active en pologne remous
politiques en perspective mais les
grévistes eux donne des signes
d'essoufflement
lech walesa se prononce pour des
pourparlers sans préalable
peut-être la fin d'un mystère dans la
région de mourmelon en champagne
l'arrestation d'un adjudant chef de 42
ans relance l'anc est sûre la
disparition inexpliquée de cette
personne
le cinéma claude berri que voici le
producteur qui prend des risques nous
ouvre les portes de son bureau en direct
c'est un événement pour fêter ses 25 ans
de cinéma berry va produire tenez vous
bien cinq films en maintenant il nous
expliquera pourquoi tout à l'heure la
mort de françoise dolto c'est l'autre
image de l'actualité françoise dolto que
d'aucuns appelée familièrement la
grand-mère de la psychanalyste c'était
un an à l'âge de 79 ans l'histoire
retiendra que toute sa vie elle a milité
inlassablement pour le respect des
enfants françoise dolto savez touché le
coeur et surtout l'intelligence du grand
public
un de ses amis a déclaré ce matin elle
était curieuse de tout elle parlait à la
fois le langage des adultes le langage
des enfants et surtout celui de la
psychanalyse c'est que c'est là qu'ils
ont une curiosité extraordinaire et une
curiosité qui n'est pas seulement de ce
qu'il voit mais de ce qu'ils perçoivent
ils perçoivent très très finement au
toucher à l'audition ils perçoivent les
nuances de la voix de quelqu'un qui leur
parle juste ou faux et c'est pour ça que
c'est si important que les parents ne
répète pas les paroles qu'on leur dit
qu'il faut dire aux enfants parce qu'ils
s'entendent très bien que c'est dû
répéter que ce n'est pas de leur cru
mais quand vous commencez à parler à des
bébés même vu comme si c'était comme
s'ils allaient pouvoir vous répondre
en fait dû quand même beaucoup se moquer
de vous il était un peu la zad service
on
on s'amusait de me voir parler avec les
enfants c'est ici dans ce bureau que
pendant 40 ans françoise dolto a appris
le langage des enfants pour mieux le
faire partager à leurs parents mais
aussi parce que pour elle une seule
cause compter celles des enfants
pédiatre et psychanalyste françoise
dolto avait la passion de l'écriture
elle a reçu ici rue saint jacques
des milliers de parents souvent
désemparés ce qu'elle voulait avant tout
que le monde de l'enfance ne soit plus
étranges et aux adultes
il a quand même marqué un tournant dans
l'histoire de la façon dont on conçoit
le psychisme des gens et puis dans ton
compte que la place des enfants le
respect d'un fond je crois que je crois
que si elle si elle voulait laisser un
message c'était respecter les enfants
quelques jours je disais que tu vas
mourir
les queues
cette expérience les renforcer non
seulement en mesure de bien vivre ses
derniers moments et dans le calme la
tournée de ce que avoir après elle
s'arrêter là et les patients là et puis
elle me racontait que pour écrire hésité
à cette pépite abl ajimi
elle aimait écrire un génie et c'est
pourquoi j'ai choisi ce livre
nous sommes en le respect pour l'enfant
comme un sujet mais aussi ils avaient la
capacité de d'être un enfant avec les
enfants en nouvelle calédonie l'image du
jour c'est la main tendue de michel
rocard au caldoches moins d'une semaine
après la signature définitive de
l'accord sur l'avenir du territoire
le premier ministre a évoqué le
changement dans l'équité je cite ces
propos nous devons at il dit réussir la
décolonisation dans le cadre des
institutions de la république pour la
première fois sur le caillou un premier
ministre avait à ses côtés jacques
lafleur pour le rpcr et jean marie
tjibaou
le leader des indépendantistes du fln
qui est ce le ton de michel rocard a
visiblement impressionné la population
de nouméa
reportage de notre envoyé spécial rachid
arhab l'image qui restera de cette
première journée néo calédonienne de
michel rocard le premier ministre
chantent la marseillaise à côté de jean
marie tjibaou silencieux est grave
au cours de son discours michel rocard
vient d'évoquer pour la première fois
publiquement son sentiment personnel sur
l'indépendance
mon souhait est qu'en 1990 vie des
populations de l'est de l'île voisine de
rester dans l'ensemble français mais en
même temps je ferai tout ce qui est bon
ou pas il était de mon devoir et le
droit constitutionnel tel écrit dans
notre constitution
ah le con energy nation s'exerce
librement loyalement équitablement ce
qui peut conduire à l'indépendance et
dans l'infidélité de confiance et non
dans la rue mesure en se rendant
personnellement nouvelle calédonie
michel rocard voulaient mettre tout le
monde au pied du mur après les accords
parisien le premier ministre est venu
dire au rpc européenne
f à vous de jouer à présent message reçu
aujourd'hui jean marie tjibaou est venu
sur terrain caldoches demain jacques
lafleur se déplaceront territoire kanak
le programme du premier ministre
respecte un équilibre politique parfait
michel rocard voudrait que cet équilibre
autant qu'il rêve pour la nouvelle
calédonie soit aussi économiques le
premier ministre a eu cette petite
phrase en terminant sa première journée
de visite
après le temps du pardon il faut que
vienne le temps du partage dans
l'hexagone voici le chiffre du chômage +
1,4 pour cent en juillet je vous le
disais tout à l'heure soit 35000 200
chômeurs supplémentaires
un très mauvais chiffres il faut
rappeler qu'en juin la hausse était de
l'ordre de 0 8% globalement la france
compte désormais un peu plus de deux
millions six cent mille chômeurs c'est
inquiétant car la situation a plutôt
tendance à s'améliorer chez la plupart
des partenaires européens
bon c'est pas réellement une surprise
gérard leclerc car jean pierre soisson
le ministre du travail avait annoncé
cent mille chômeurs de plus à l'horizon
fin 88 absolument est la principale
explication c'est l'essoufflement du
traitement social mis en place par
philippe séguin des milliers de jeunes
ou des chômeurs de longue durée sont
achevés au début de l'été des stages
commencé à l'automne dernier ils doivent
maintenant attendre la rentrée pour
retrouver un nouveau stage autre
phénomène lié aux vacances
les fins de contrats à durée déterminée
ou d'intérim en forte progression mais
il y a aussi des raisons plus
structurelles qui font que la france ne
connaît pas l'amélioration observée
depuis deux ans en grande bretagne ou
aux états unis l'économie française ne
crée pas suffisamment d'emplois pour
absorber chaque mois dix huit mille
nouveaux arrivants sur le marché du
travail
problème de formation également un jeune
sur quatre kits encore l'école sans
réelle qualification
enfin difficultés pour sortir du chômage
on y reste en moyenne un an beaucoup
plus longtemps que chez nos voisins
au delà de la béquille du traitement
social c'est sur ces trois points qu'il
faut agir
merci gérard 88 décidément année noire
pour la sncf on a appris tout à l'heure
qu'un train de voyageurs avait percuté
un butoir en gare saint-charles à
marseille
selon les premiers témoignages notamment
les témoignages des pompiers qui nous
sont parvenues il y aurait huit blessés
légers la direction régionale de la sncf
parle d'incidents mais d' incident bénin
toujours à marseille on vient
d'apprendre
on vient plutôt de retrouver les auteurs
présumé du casse de la caisse d'epargne
la sphère souvenez-vous remonte au 9
février 87
les malfaiteurs avaient tenu en haleine
pendant près de 12 heures les policiers
marseillais avant de s'enfuir par les
égouts le casse avait rapporté près de
10 millions de francs je pense que nous
aurons des images et les premiers
témoignages dans le courant de cette
édition
en pologne le pays reste en ébullition
même si la révolte ouvrière donne
quelques signes d'essoufflement
lech walesa s'est prononcé cet après
midi en faveur de pourparlers sans
préalable
c'est important avec le gouvernement
mais ce sous l'égide de l'église
catholique
je vous rappelle que hier un premier
contact avait eu lieu entre le pouvoir
et les grévistes demain nouvelle étape
importante un vaste débat va s'engager
lors du comité central du parti
communiste polonais tout le monde
s'attend sur place et dans les jours qui
viennent à de sérieux remous politiques
jacques merlino il y a une semaine les
cheveux les sa lancée d'un ultimatum au
gouvernement le sommant de reconnaître
légalement solidarity aujourd'hui il
déclare qu'il est prêt à négocier sans
aucun préalable
c'est donc un échec due pour l'essentiel
au fait qu'il n'a pu développer un grand
mouvement de grève
celui ci est restée limitée est dense et
achète chine mais c'est un échec relatif
car il semble bien maintenant que la
partie va se dérouler ici au parlement
polonais dès la semaine prochaine est
tout à fait vraisemblable que le premier
ministre actuel monsieur bnews meissner
soit conduit à donner sa démission
il pourrait être remplacé par monsieur
vladislav baccar gouverneur de la banque
centrale
un homme qui a la réputation d'être plus
un réaliste qu'un idéal information qui
pourrait être confirmé demain après la
réunion du comité du parti communiste
polonais un mort 40 blessés plusieurs
centaines de sans abri peut être plus
c'est le dernier bilan du gigantesque
incendie qui a ravagé hier le quartier
historique de lisbonne au portugal
aujourd'hui la zone sinistrée et placé
sous haute surveillance la police craint
visiblement des actions de pillage et de
vandalisme reste les courses de l'
incendie
on en est encore pour l'instant qu'au
stade des hypothèses reportage de
dominique verdeilhan notre envoyé
spécial dans une ville traumatisée en
proie à la désolation apocalyptique de
l'iss
tout un périmètre de la capitale
désertée comme après un cataclysme un
bombardement un séisme l'incendiaire a
meurtri le centre ville de lisbonne
banques boutiques et de nombreux bureaux
ont été touchés c'est tout ce qui reste
du grand magasin le grande et là là où
tout a commencé
vous voulez ici c'est un peu comme le le
premier le deuxième arrondissement de
paris si vous voulez hein c'est à dire
c'est principalement bureaux activités
économiques
mais à côté de ça il y avait quand même
surtout des personnes âgées 1 ce soir
les pompiers continuent d'arroser les
façades à tout moment des blocs de
pierre menace de s'écraser sur les
sauveteurs 36 heures de lutte acharnée
pour tenter de sauver leur quartier
douze pompiers ont été blessés de ce
soir sont dans un état grave
c'est une tristesse pour moi et pour
tous les textes est celle d'une
désolation
j'essaie dé jacques lemaire a déjà que
prostituée commission ou deux
faire là cet après-midi les assureurs se
sont rendus sur place pour tenter
d'évaluer le préjudice mais seulement
10% des personnes sinistrées avait
contacté une assurance autre bilan de
cette catastrophe
plus de 300 sans abri et plus de 3000
personnes au chômage technique une
activité commerciale stoppé pour
plusieurs mois même si les bâtiments
vont être répartis au cul des portes
c'est pas un peu c'est pas possible de
le faire c'était à buller c'est une perf
physique et émotionnel
et donc c'est la vie dans casa bataille
le plus vieux magasin du quartier date
de 753 il avait survécu au séisme de
1755 mail incendies d'hier lui a été
fatale à dieu quitterait un quotidien
portugais ce matin lisbonne c'est ce
soir qu'elle a perdu un peu de son passé
mais télégramme d'actualité avec laurent
bouvier ensuite nous parlerons politique
eh oui c'est l'heure des universités
d'été ils ont tellement un réseau
d'espionnage en suède et en allemagne de
l'ouest
un réseau qui travaillait depuis dix ans
pour la hongrie suis personnes ont été
arrêtées dont deux frères des médecins
hongrois et un ancien sous-officier
america longtemps basé en r & spa le
sergent clyde lit conrad
parmi les documents qui auraient été
vendus à la hongrie les plans américains
de décence
en cas d' attaques de l'europe par
l'urss
union soviétique toujours mais côté
agriculture cette fois les paysans
russes pourront maintenant devenir
propriétaires de leurs terres
l'agent sas l'a annoncé aujourd'hui le
comité d'état avant industriel a
approuvé cette mesure proposée par
mikhaïl gorbatchev le 29 juillet dernier
une autorisation qui ou une brèche dans
la politique de collectivisation a posé
sous staline en france
réapparition des incendies de forêt la
nuit dernière 6 à 800 hectares de maquis
et de garrigues ont été détruits en
haute-corse où une cinquantaine de
foyers d'origine criminelle aurait été
allumé en moins de 10 heures dans le var
et l'hérault 500 contre 80 véhicules et
des canadairs ont lutté pour venir à
bout d'une dizaine de cynisme qui ont
ravagé 150 hectares de pinède
c'est la première alerte importante dans
le sud du pays qui fait années avait été
relativement épargné par ses
traditionnels catastrophe
je vous le disais à l'instant les ténors
politiques se succèdent en haute savoie
le point de rencontre c'est la commune
de sévrier près d'annecy où se déroule
l'université d'été du parti socialiste
ce matin les militants ont écouté
attentivement jean poperen parler de
cohésion sociale cet après midi c'est
pierre mauroy qui a pris le relais
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste a proposé aux socialistes un
grand débat pour l'année 1990
jean-michel mercurey près de rennes pour
pierre mauroy fini la confusion d'après
législatives la majorité existe bel et
bien
le gouvernement travaill ait réussi bref
c'est la clarté aujourd'hui estime
pierre mauroy
le mérite en revient il est vrai à
françois mitterrand lui même avec son
intervention du 14 juillet exit donc les
petites joutes qui font le quotidien de
la démocratie pour le patron du ps le
rassemblement a définitivement supplanté
l'ouverture se veut de plus par les
ouvertures cette manière vous comprenez
que l'ouverture qui entraîne la
confusion
et c'est pas souhaitable continuer avec
un zèle vocable un majorité
présidentielle une majorité de
rassemblement et d'une majorité qui peut
s'élargir
c'est par conséquent une majorité qui
restent ouvertes à qui reste ouverte à
ceux qui défendent des idées ont été
présentées au pays par louis dans la
république
rassuré d'être la force prépondérante
assuré de détenir la durée le ps
s'inquiète pourtant déjà de son avenir
au delà du septennat et la proche de
l'an 2000 les socialistes vont donc
engager une vaste réflexion sur leur
identité
objectif adapter la doctrine et
moderniser les structures une rénovation
promis pour 10 990 une année prévue pour
le maman sans aucune élection
voilà retour à marseille où l'on vient
de retrouver je vous le disais tout à
l'heure les auteurs présumé du casse du
célèbre casse de la caisse d'epargne
affaire remonte au 9 février 1987 savait
que les auteurs du casse s'étaient
enfuis par les égouts en embarquant la
coquette somme de 10 millions de francs
le rappel des faits d'autres compléments
d'information avec agnès poirier un
quartier entier bouclé toute une journée
par les forces de police le raid est
robert broussard directeur des polices
urbaines sont descendus de paris
à l'intérieur de cette caisse d'epargne
en plein marseille des malfaiteurs
détiennent 23 personnes en otages les
employés et tous les clients
le suspense va durer 12 heures et puis
les gangsters repartent comme ils sont
arrivés le plus tranquillement du monde
par les égouts ils emportent avec eux le
contenu de 300 coffre plus de 10
millions de francs six mois après le
casse en septembre 87
les policiers du srpj de marseille
arrête en espagne de des gangsters avec
une partie du butin
depuis ce matin 12 malfaiteurs certains
déjà condamné pour vol à main armée sont
en garde à vue pour les policiers la
bande du casse de marseille est
aujourd'hui sous les verrous
à paris dans la capitale les contours de
l'escroquerie autour des parcmètres
commencent à se décider tout doucement
en l'absence de faits nouveaux et
surtout d'explication officielle de la
part du constructeur ou de la ville de
paris une équipe d'antenne 2 a pu
localiser aujourd'hui le centre de
collecte des parcs m alors à partir de
là elle a essayé de démonter le
mécanisme de l'escroquerie enquête du
service société de la rédaction
d'antenne de commenter par rémy roche
nous sommes sous la place de la concorde
c'est dans ce parking dans une zone un
peu à part que se trouve le seul centre
de collecte de la recette des
horodateurs parisien 270 millions de
francs par an en pièces de monnaie qui
sont derrière cette porte trier et mise
en rouleau avant d'être convoyés vers la
banque de france rangés le long du local
une quinzaine de véhicules municipaux et
deux motos de grosse cylindrée sous
scellés elles appartiennent à des
employés du centre aujourd'hui inculpé
et écroué
arrivée d'une équipe de collecte à
l'intérieur du fourgon quatre de ces
fameuses aspirateur qui permettent en
principe en toute sécurité de recueillir
la recette de 10 euros date heure chacun
en effet lors de l'aspiration les
employés n'ont aucun contact avec les
pièces et les conteneurs sont plombés en
fait il semble que c'est dans le fourgon
pendant le trajet entre le lieu de
collecte et le centre de tri que les
conteneurs étaient des plombes est
évident et pour partie de leur contenu
ce qui nécessitait la complicité
d'autres employés du centre chargé du
déplombage à l'arrivée opération qui se
déroulait pourtant sous contrôle vidéo
est théoriquement en présence de l'un
des cinq anciens fonctionnaires de
police chargés de la surveillance ce
soir 21 des 49 employés du service sont
déjà inculpées certains échos et ce qui
laisse penser qu'une bonne partie du
service avait connaissance voire
profiter du trafic pour l'instant évalué
à 20 millions de francs
précision importante j'ajoute que
l'ensemble du service est donc entendue
par la police mais la collecte reprendra
lundi prochain la ville de paris vient
de faire savoir que 25 inspecteurs
assermentés ont été réquisitionnés pour
l'occasion peut-être de nouveau dans la
sphère de mourmelon mourmelon en
champagne et cette petite ville de
garnison qui se trouve au coeur d'un
triangle où cette disparition
inexpliquée ont été constatés depuis
1981 il ya quelques semaines
l'arrestation d'un adjudant
chef de 42 ans accusé d'avoir torturé
violé un jeune touriste a brusquement
relancer l'on fait la quête l'enquète
pardon pour l'instant pas de lien direct
entre les deux affaires mais quelques
coïncidences troublantes quand même
patrice bellet pierre chanal alias rambo
pour ses amis adjudant-chef solitaire et
réserver sa passion le parachutisme
qu'il venait pratiqué à mourmelon sur ce
terrain d'aviation
aujourd'hui il est inculpé de viol et
écroué pour sévices sexuels sur un jeune
auto stoppeurs étrangers indice
principal trouver dans son camping car
un sous vêtement masculin de marque
anglaise questions des enquêteurs at il
a appartenu à trevor o'keefe
ce jeune irlandais découvert étranglé en
87 dans le département de l'aisne
mais pierre chanal est aussi le suspect
numéro un dans la sphère de mourmelon 6
appelé et un civil tous disparu entre 80
et 87 dans le même secteur géographique
sur les nationales qui joignent les camp
de mourmelon mailly et suivent dans la
marne
toujours le même scénario des parents
stop et puis plus rien aucune trace
pierre chanal nie toute participation à
ces disparitions
mais l' enquête relève des coïncidences
troublantes chanal a passé sept ans au
4e régiment de dragons de mourmelon 7
ans pendant lesquels ont eu lieu la
plupart des disparitions mystérieuses
et puis c'est dans le régiment de chanel
qui était incorporé quatre des six
appelé disparu mais là s'arrêtent les
coïncidences et comanche l'enquète pour
les gendarmes pas de preuve pour le
moment cet arrêt battoir n'a pas permis
de mettre en cause de le mettre en cause
dans les disparitions
c'est une piste que nous prenons très au
sérieux comme toutes les pistes et que
nous explorons encore actuellement
travail de fourmi pour les gendarmes il
leur faut contrôler 10 années d'emploi
du temps de pierre chanal sans sa
collaboration
l'adjudant-chef véritable homme de
guerre selon ses supérieurs se retranche
derrière un mutisme complet le sport et
plus particulièrement l'automobile alain
prost jouera le tout pour le tout
dimanche sur le circuit international de
spa francorchamps en belgique pour
conserver une chance face à senna prost
doit l'emporter à tout prix apparemment
ça sera dur dur car le brésilien ayrton
senna
a réalisé le meilleur temps des essais
officiels cet après-midi sénat le
brésilien devance alain proch notre
champion garber guerre et l'italien
michele alboreto affaire à suivre
le cinéma un événement dans le journal
d'antenne 2 nous avons rendez vous ce
soir avec le plus grand producteur
indépendant du cinéma français claude
berri nous accueille chez lui mais oui
pour fêter à la fois ses 25 ans de
carrière et pour nous annoncer un
programme impressionnant berry tenez
vous bien pas produire cinq films en un
an
michel pascal vous êtes avec nous en
direct effectivement et c'est un
programme impressionnant et un sacré
défi puisque claude berri va investir
tenez vous bien 450 millions de francs
45 milliards de centimes
sur ces cinq crimes et je propose
d'abord de parler de cet anniversaire de
ses 25 ans de cinéma et de tous les
films qui sont nés ici dans le bureau
nous nous trouvons dans ce bureau qui
est à deux pas des champs-elysées un
événement que la presse souligne
aujourd'hui aussi bien dans le journal
le monde que dans le magazine de cinéma
première alors pour vous mettre un petit
peu dans l'ambiance
je propose d'abord une petite promenade
en images dans le cinéma de claude berri
regarder du vieil homme et l'enfant en
1966 jusqu'aux prochaines liaisons
dangereuses de milos forman valmont il
sortira en 89 en passant par les 17
millions d'entrées de florette manon des
sources
claude berri aligne un palmarès
impressionnant 12 films réalisé une
cinquantaine de productions
il n'y a pas de genre mineur ou majeur
pour claude berri qui passe de claude
zidi aroman polanski de pierre richard a
remis schneider
et qui donne à coluche ses plus grands
rôles comiques et tragiques
un seul mot compte pour lui faire du
cinéma populaire et il va le prouver
dans ses prochains films de molinaro à
l'ours de jean jacques annaud de jacques
demy à la petite voleuse de claude
miller
il relève le défi fou du cinéma français
claude berri le mot crise n'existe pas
claude berri bonsoir et merci de nous
accueillir dans votre bureau je crois
que c'est en soi une première
première question directe pourquoi cette
boli cette boulimie soudaine cinq films
en un an c'est pratiquement du jamais vu
pour un producteur indépendant
donc c'est plutôt une question de fin de
hasard l'ours s'est tourné l'année
dernière cette année se sont tournés les
films de molinaro de jacques demy et
claude miller et le film de milos forman
a commencé au mois d'août et se
terminera en janvier
qu'est ce qui vous motive dans le choix
des films que vous produisez ce qui
motive c'est l' envie de les faire l'
envie de les montrer mais vous vous
disiez tout à l'heure
patrice pour claude berri ça dépend
beaucoup du public
mais moi je ne crois pas aujourd'hui que
le que la crise du cinéma elle et c'est
le public qui en est la cause moi je
crois que ce sont le plus que ce sont
les produits qui sont en cause et j'ai
essayé c'est un défi que je relève avec
ces cinq films de voir si on donne des
films aux spectateurs s'ils vont pas se
déranger parce qu'aujourd'hui à la vidéo
il ya la télévision les films doivent
passer la télévision un jour mais avant
tout lé le plaisir du spectateur il est
en salle mais les films coûtent 40
francs dérange pas les gens pour rien et
moi je vais essayer je voudrais qu'on
fasse confiance
il ya 25 ans tu fais des films on les a
pas ce toutou cité j'aime aussi le
cinéma d'auteur j'ai produit ou
coproduit adieu bonaparte de youssef
chahine les films de de patrice chéreau
de doillon de pialat
j'aime aussi un certain cinéma je ne
suis pas sectaire sur les genres vous
prenez des risques que vous avez
l'impression on va parler concrètement
on va parler gros sous
tchao pantin par exemple aux amis
combien 25 millions dans tchao pantin
oui à l'époque les prunes a coûté 25
millions ça vous a rapporté combien si
je suis pas indiscret ça va pas dans la
poche saveurs dans la société ça
retourne dans le cinéma
je sais pas dans le temps parce que
maintenant il faut tenir compte aussi
qu'on revend les films à la télévision
dans le temps tchao pantin pu rapporter
chez pas peut-être 30 millions que c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur exemple jean
de florette par exemple là je suis bien
assis sur mon fauteuil donnez-moi le
schisme weeds jean jean de florette si
on tient compte de la recette pour le
distributeur de tous les pourcentages
accordé à mon temps à jacqueline pagnol
à 2
dieu à moi même et à rennes production
comme je crois que j'en fleurette à des
années et des années dans le ventre de
justement de télévision peut-être que
sais je sais pas moi 150 millions après
ça on peut prendre des risques mais je
les prends moi ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde et c'est pour ça que les
gens vont pas au cinéma parce qu'on fait
des films des petits films avec l'argent
qu'on trouve 10 15 millions ou fait des
téléfilms on se couvre et les gens
s'ennuient au cinéma et seul pascal en
avant première on peut peut-être voir un
des cinq films produits par par claude
berri absolument va voir quelques
premières images du film d'edouard
molinaro qui s'appelle à gauche en
sortant de l'ascenseur qui est
l'adaptation d'une pièce de boulevard de
gérard lauzier avec des acteurs assez
formidable vous allez le voir puisque à
pierre richard richard bohringer
emmanuelle béart et j'oubliais fanico
tension serré je sais pas ce qui m'a
pris
elles étaient tous contre moi il il
faisait chaud je sentais ses 50 ans ma
poitrine
son parfum les j'arrête là on continue
j'aime à souffrir ce tome la tenue et
mélange les prix dans mes bras et je les
embrasse le bol a su passer sa journée
au bar de comédie à touver de 20 km
autour de chez lui il a le droit de
savoir c'est vrai nous je me soucie vous
avez fait la moindre ascenseur
oui bien sûr ça n'a pas été facile parce
que je ne sais pas si vous voyez la
cabine cela dit j'ai fait dix ans dit
aux gars alors la règle d'or c'est de
plaire au public ça va marcher ça michel
pasteur on a écouté je pense que ça va
marcher parce que c'est un film on l'a
vu hier en projection publique et il a
il a fait énormément rire la salle alors
votre secret claude berri justement
c'est de toujours viser le grand public
et de faire un cinéma vraiment populaire
non pas du tout quand je produis le
blesser je lis pas je vise pas forcément
le grand public je vise un bon film non
mais là en l'occurrence le feu
le film de molinaro c'est un film très
populaire très drôle et moi j'aime bien
le mélange des genres je peux produire
molinaro je peux produire milos forman
richard là il a un rôle taillé sur
mesure annonce qu'on vient de voir
écoutez j'ai fait sept films avec lui et
c'est le cinquième film que je fais avec
pierre richard et je pense qu'en france
aujourd'hui le cinéma comique se meurt
il ya plus de films drôles ya plus de
films comiques
bon on peut faire une petite parenthèse
avec la vie est un long fleuve
tranquille qui est un film très original
dans une avec des acteurs absolument
inconnu ou où l'on s'amuse où l'on
s'amuse souvent dans le film mais je
vous garantis que si on emmenait un
huissier dans la salle et qu'on fasse et
qu'on contrôle si on rigole plus long
fleuve tranquille qui a à gauche en
sortant de l'ascenseur
je prends les paris qu on rigolera plus
à gauche en sortant de l'ascenseur pour
en finir à vous poser la question sur
pierre richard depuis la mort de de
funès et coluche je pense que pierre
richard est la seule grande vedette
comique du film et je demande aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils me regardent et
qui m'écoutent fait moins confiance
allez voir les cinq films commencer par
qu'une de molinaro je crois que depuis
25 ans je l'éprouvé je ne trahis pas le
spectateur
merci à tous les quatre nous avoir
accueillis ce soir on en accepte
l'auguré merci les pronostics du tiercé
et du quarté pour demain c'est à
vincennes il y à quatorze partants voici
les pronostics de notre ami pierrette
brès le 14 le 6 le 13 le neuf
l'un lasse plus tôt le 5 le 2 et le 4 le
14 le 6 le 13 le 9 las le 5 le 2 et le 4
voilà j'en ai presque terminée dans
quelques instants
la météo du week-end avec josé blanc
lapierre dernier journal présenté tout à
l'heure par aubry et de l'air aux
alentours de 23h15 samedi et dimanche
vous avez rendez vous avec l'équipe du
huitième d'antenne 2
aux commandes betty bureau devant la
caméra à ma place daniel bilalian je
vous retrouve lundi à 20h merci de votre
fidélité et bonsoir
monde
à